好了,我是小三年,你今天这期视频下来给你们分享一下
我是小二号,只过今天有哪些东西是很值得买的
大家可以暗锡中草
小二号是我说是一个第一个大场直播也是我的生日场
所以我动和积智呢,算是今年以来非常非常炸的嘛
那飞滑不多说,首先是这个加充满的光
它其实是加上用点这里,我很少给大家上最久
比它用内的一切,因为这种东西呢,是起来周期特别长
而且很容易,看到效果就对在角落里吃回,但是这台引起我觉得它是用一次
就能看到一次的效果的,像通由一斗啊,那次配了嘛,它都可以坚持用一段时间
皮膚真的是肉眼可见的变息你,然后这次的机制也很不错
大家日常驾驶,自积智五百八十八,在我的直播间呢,是两千九百八十八
把锅肉一堆一堆的智皮红石呢,还支持七天生用有皮的简单
真的可以试试它
但来,就是我的常年绑疫情华三休军华
我直播了多少时间,我就上了它多少时间
而且它是我直播间副够率最高的一华,可想而知它有多好用的吧
它的但都有效果非常非常有,不管一点效果,都一是亲心灵灵,还是那种成片是很骗的
它都可以N倍速给你消下去,像有很多几位都是用完了两斤之后呢,皮膚就像一件模型的一样,很感激
因为它的消耗比较快,所以呢,我推荐大家入手双之装,而且双之装的机制也是非常非常的好的
相当于是买二,送二,再送两片冰武,用一个大半年,我觉得都是抽抽油油油油
接下来是绑拉的这个N先加一场精环的套土,它们两个是我为数多的,让我用完之后,能感受到苏芒口效果的呼吸
我们常见的毛孔分会,缺水晶,出有型和刷一老型
但是它们这一对CP基本上都照顾到了,或者那一场呼吸都已经离不开这两个东西了
它们让我脸加,这两边的毛孔变得新的很多很多,而且会让我的膚色很均匀
这两个就是属于只要坚持用皮膚的质感和气色东西的很好,这一趟日常是1千一百三
直播到首试,六百九十九,相当于是打六九,然后视频中精华,每次有游定比前面我推荐产品,我都会毫不游预的推荐它
它真的太好用了,你有了它就相当于有了一支少不舍加,不顺精华,加修顾警华
再加上它的修顾的这个思路也是比较全面的,可以开火,可以你还能够湖水,然后修顾平常,所以很多外游内感前面
连续用上几周就发现自己的皮膚好几期发表了,而且也有减肥斗反夸,它对于一骂肉的效果也是不出气的好,非常适合加中场,对,这次它的纯会装真是很好,相当于是买三,送三,还送精华水,到首试,因为千零四十七,所以喜欢的减肥可以找好不用一起皮膚,然后是,加上挺反韩,很需要闭背的,可以投到出现,这个是我今年用起来觉得清潔用好,但是又不可能硬碗,去年,不为了给大家找一看好的到出现,我前面会会用了好多好多,
用了一上面,就是裤辣辣的它很刺激,然后还用一线的富碗之后,样跟就服务出油脂袋,但是它的滑脑就是跟不解油脂的效果很好,稍微服务一下,你配合肉盆,再配合黑豆产,就可以把毛孔里的油脂,轻松产出,用啥呢,也不会觉得,四桶或者是不舒服,在它是我们的朋友,都给你一圈刷,这个也是我们直播间,富光率非常高的一块面刷,特别是和油脂一年刺激用的一款修顾面刷,它上练我看之后,立刻就会发成水,
快乐就会被皮膚给吃进去,其实我身后就像在脸上,照那层,保护我一样持续的皮膚鼠水,在皮膚明明的时候,还可以拿它做,你就会面我去后腹,脸上那种紧崩,干净套啊,不舒服的情况很快,这个被压下去,然后它这次的鸡汁也是非常好做,三辣二十五买五十克,送五十五克的中小样,送的饼卖的还要多